the uk must cut its global environmental
footprint by
75 by 2030 according to a new report by
the world wildlife fund the wwf joining
us now mark wright
director of science at the worldwide
fund for nature mark
great to have you on the program this
morning um explain
exactly what what what this must me what
this means for the uk if we suggest
that we need to see our environmental
footprint cut by 75
what sort of world will we be living in
okay well let's remember why we're
asking for this in the first place and
it's quite clear that
all the things we buy the food we eat
are fueling the loss of nature
and also increasing the risk of climate
change so clearly something has to be
done
so we're calling for a three-quarter
slashing of our footprint let's remember
this is
just what's happening in the uk it's
also kind of
factors in the things we import from
overseas as well the food we bring from
oc's the clothes the cars and so on
but what the report also says is
basically speaking there's a lot of
flexibility in the system we can make
those
changes there's really substantial
changes without massively impacting our
lives so don't forget the government has
already committed to a 78
reduction in greenhouse gases so these
things are perfectly doable
and actually the economy could benefit
as results as well
give us some examples of though mark
because frankly it will be music to
everyone's ears if we can we can make
those type of gains in terms of our
environmental impact
without there being a corresponding and
equally significant effect on well
frankly let's be selfish about
our own lives okay well let's use food
because we know that food is a real
driver for
losses around the world so in this
country it might be surprised to hear
that
we waste about 10 million tons of food
and drink
every single year 10 million tons so
just think about what it costs to reduce
that in terms of time
resources processing transport and so on
so that's horrifying that we we waste 10
billion tons
but 70 percent of that is perfectly
edible so if we could kind of
rework the system so that we're not kind
of throwing this stuff away
and of course that 30 percent is none
edible for us
is edible for plenty of other things for
example insects and they're really good
systems
up and running already to take food
waste
feed it to insects and then we feed
those insects to chickens
rather than giving them soy which came
from latin america
and it was produced by cutting down
rainforest and clearing grasslands and
so on so there's a real
win-win situation so what are the
consequences what are the potential
consequences that would follow from us
not being so ambitious in our our
targets to reduce our environmental
impact
well i think the the images you're
showing here show us the impacts i mean
only these last couple of years we've
seen just extraordinary outbursts of
you know fires around the world you know
the horrible fires missing in british
columbia at the moment
cyclists i saw yesterday but yeah
siberia amazon australia we're seeing
these
extreme weather events they those will
become the norms sadly
and we know that we're losing species
around the world as well and
don't forget since 1900 if 500
types of vertebrates have gone extinct
so these are animals no one will ever
see again
and that those risks will increase as if
we don't take action now
mark wright good to see you this morning
thanks very much for being with us